so
good afternoon everyone my name is peter
salovey i'm the 23rd president of yale
university
welcome to this historic moment for yale
it's a pleasure and
a privilege to have the honor of
introducing a
very distinguished visitor to our campus
united nations secretary-general ban
ki-moon
your excellency thank you thank you for
coming to yale and i note that this is
your third such visit and each time you
have inspired our community with your
wise perspective
and thank you most especially for the
united nations and your personal deep
care
for the preservation of cultural
heritage and sponsorship of this
important colloquium
when we embarked on our planning
for the events of this week
for the un global colloquium of
university presidents
itself which will take place tomorrow
and for the wider program of activities
that are
taking place including this public
lecture the response from the yale
community was one of immediate
and resonant enthusiasm
for our faculty and our students
and our employees and community members
across new haven
the topic at hand struck a vibrant cord
preservation of cultural cultural
heritage challenges and strategies
for us at yale hosting this year's
global colloquium there could be no
question that this would be our subject
of focus
why
well because quite simply heritage
matters
it is the record both concrete and
intangible
of human identity
when our heritage is destroyed
by war
or by weather
from malice or from neglect it is a loss
that in many cases can never be
remedied
so we at yale are delighted to have the
support and cooperation of the united
nations
and the collaboration of so many
individuals across our own campus
and from institutions around the world
in seeking to protect
preserve and promote our shared cultural
heritage
as i said earlier
this week's colloquium and surrounding
events
have met with an overwhelming response
from our community
you here in this room today
are a testament to the importance and
the resonance
of our work our work together
more than 150 faculty members and other
experts across the university
from widely varied backgrounds and
diverse fields of study and practice
are contributing not only to this week's
programs but to ongoing preservation and
conservation efforts
i hope that many of you took advantage
of yesterday's open house at yale's west
campus
to see the work taking place at the
institute for the preservation of
cultural heritage
if you missed it there's another open
house on friday
and too many other events to name but
you can read all about them at ungc un
global colloquium ungc dot yel
dot edu
secretary general then during your last
visit to yell in 2012
you spoke so eloquently of the need for
collective action
to confront the world's greatest
challenges
you called upon us to seek alliances
among nations
among institutions
to share the responsibility for
protecting
our world
we heard you that day
and we felt the same sense of urgency
that you
expressed and i'm very proud to say that
the work you see taking place at yale
today
and with institutional partners around
the globe
is a manifestation of that belief
your excellency you have inspired us
with your leadership of the united
nations
you have made important strides toward
peace
you've reached out to nations in crisis
you've worked diligently to promote the
rights of women to protect the
environment and to strengthen the united
nations and make it more effective
for generations to come
thank you so much for your leadership in
confronting climate change and fostering
sustainability
issues on which yale shares your deep
commitment
you have brought the nations of the
world together
achieved concerted and concrete action
with the tremendous success of cop 21 in
paris
as a sign of real hope
you've also done so much to encourage
young people to participate in civic
life
leading by example as you as you have
engaged with youth
listen to them and help them to find
their voices
on the world stage
at yale as educators and as committed
global citizens we're delighted to have
the united nations as a partner in
supporting the next generation of
citizen leaders
when it comes to conserving and
preserving cultural heritage and shared
history
we at yale like to say the future of the
past
is in our hands in all of our hands
and in the hands
of every individual around the world
mr secretary general right here and
right now we are in your hands
we are eager to have your insights
to learn from your perspective
and to go forth from today
inspired to do even more
to contribute to the vital work
that lies ahead
thank you for being with us today and
everyone please join me
in giving a very warm welcome to united
nations secretary-general ban ki-moon
thank you distinguished president peter
salovey
of yale university
distinguished the presence of
universities around the world
honorable members of the academic
communities
distinguished faculties
dear students
ladies and gentlemen
it's a great honor and pleasure for me
to visit
the yale university again for third time
as a secretary general
and take part in the united nations
global colloquium
i'm inspired to be among some of the
most distinguished
academics in the world
and to connect your groundbreaking
research with the global diplomacy of
the united nations
i was energized
and inspired
by our previous meetings which covered
maternal health
empowering young people
and harnessing new technologies
to meet global challenges
i'm particularly happy to see
so many young students out here today
who will be
surely the leaders of tomorrow
but
most of them have already taken the
leadership of today
it's important that for this
collection
to
discuss about how we can how the
teachers and professors can provide good
and sustainable
opportunities
social political and economic
opportunities for
young people
ladies and gentlemen standing here as a
secretary
i'm just thinking of
what will happen after me as you may
know or may not know
from today the selection process of my
success has begun at the united nations
this is going to be very different the
selection process
i'm very happy that there is going to be
a change
in the united nations system
this is a huge change
when
i was
elected as a secretary general in 2006
i was one of the many candidates
jokingly i've been saying that
well you know i'm the first
democratically elected secretary general
why
before me
there was
no such secret general seven secretaries
generals who were elected through
campaign
i was the only one
at that time seven candidates
who have been campaigning in fact i'm
very happy
to see a form of
president of mexico said you're sitting
here
he was
you may remember
i'll tell you all the secrets
i when i was a candidate
i was invited by
davos forum world economic forum
there were several
several candidates that was the first
time that i was having sort of an
interview in front of maybe a thousand
people president cedillo
was moderator
moderator he was giving hard questions
hard questions
i'd like to thank very much for his
vision
then he might have thought that
i could be
some possible
possible candidate or secretary general
i think his question was a little bit
softer than other people other
candidates
thank you for that but for me every
question was a difficult one
today
this
this campaign has really begun the
inter-general assembly hall
all 193 member states together with
ngo
representatives and they were
questioning
the candidates we have four women four
men candidates and these number of
candidates will be
will be
surely increasing in any way this is a
good
a very good way to change
this world in a more transparent
more competitive more accountable way
accountable way i was one of them
i
i think myself i was elected through
that but this process will be much much
more competitive and much more a
transparent one that's a good for the
future of the united nations let's
hope for the best and if possible
let us hope that the best candidate
could be
a woman candidate
next from next year
all what i said is off the record today
well ladies and gentlemen
i'm particularly
honored to be here
and it is appropriate
that we did we are discussing
here at the yale
where
this destruction
destruction of
cultural treasures on a vast scale
over recent years
make
this our theme of this collection even
more timely and relevant
it's appropriate that we discussed this
here at yale
where the world famous
bainetke library
and the institute for the preservation
of cultural heritage
have done so much to raise awareness of
culture in crisis
president sullivan i know you have taken
this important course far beyond yale
including to the world economic forum at
davos this year
where you devoted yale's
annual event
to discussing ancient artifacts from
babylon and palmyra
on behalf of the united nations i'd like
to thank you
and to express our great admiration for
your commitment to humanity
many distinguished speakers are here to
share their experience on preserving
cultural heritage
as a secretary general i have been
visiting
many historical places where i saw so
many precious timeless
valuable
heritages
each time whenever i
wrote the guest book
i've been always saying that
i'm very much impressed inspired by what
i have seen today here but these are
common assets
of
humanity these should be preserved
for coming generations so that they will
be inspired
this has been my standard the writing
all the times
today
i'd like to put the preservation of
culture into a geopolitical context
to show why we at the united nations
believe
it is essential to our mission
of peace and security sustainable
development
and human rights
distinguished university presidents
dear students ladies and gentlemen
art
literature
music poetry
architecture
these are the hallmarks of our human
existence
they form a common thread
that unites all civilizations and
cultures
a celebration of our emotional lives
and the beauty
of our national environment
our cultural heritage
defines our humanity
cultural diversity
like biodiversity
plays a quantifiable and crucial part
in the health of human species
on attack on cultural heritage in our in
one part of the world is an attack
on us all
on all of us humanity
but cultural diversity
is on the grave threat
around the globe
this is very sad at this time
who could fail
to be outraged by the destruction
of the magnificent buddhas
of bamiya
bamiyan the monument of palmyra
the mosques and cultural artifacts
in northern mali
this wonton vandalism and destruction is
not collateral damage
it's a part of a ruthless
wave of cultural
and ethnic cleansing
inseparable
from the prosecution of the communities
that created these cultural gems
it's also part of a cycle of theft
and profit that finances
the activities of extremists and
terrorists
as a human family
we cannot let them erase our history and
identity
any loss of cultural heritage is a loss
of our common
memory
it impairs
our ability to learn
to build the experience
and to apply the lessons of the past to
the present and the future
culture is also one of the strongest
driving forces for building societies
and imbuing
them with values
it needs communities together
with the sense of community
extremists and terrorists
have known this
throughout the ages
they have always understood
that by attacking and destroying
cultural artifacts
buildings and monuments
they can divide the people
they can erase their common values
shred the
social fabric
and create greater
fragility and vulnerability to their
cynical ideology
in our response
we must even be
more determined to safeguard
and preserve culture
than the extremists are to destroy
this must be central
to our strategy for tackling
violent extremism and building peace and
restoring a security
the united nations system is working to
strengthen the links between protection
of cultural cultural heritage
peace building missions
and humanitarian emergency response
last last week last friday
in
geneva i have convened an international
conference at ministerial level
to talk about
my plan of action
to prevent the violent extremism
there were 700
people from 120 countries all
participating this was warmly welcomed
by the united nations general assembly
in february and i'm in the process of
implementing
and
executing all this plan of action so
that
we will be able to first of all prevent
this violent extremism it's important
that we fight back and defeat terrorism
extremism at the same time it's much
more important to prevent
before these things happen
once a terrorist happens terrorist
actions happens
it's a cruel and brutal and it's very
tragic
but if we can prevent
those
extremism and terrorism from taking
place i think that's the way we can save
our human lives
and our cultural artifacts that's very
important
point priority for the united nations at
this time
ladies and gentlemen i visit mali
for example in mali i saw the
destruction
caused by extremist militants
to muslims and many manuscripts when
they took over timbuktu
in 2012.
i visited mali immediately after that
it was not only about stones
buildings and papers
it was about identity and human dignity
i'll never forget
speaking to the grand imam
representatives from the christian
community the local governments young
people and women's representatives
they all said
they had lived together in a diverse
community for thousand years
they all wanted education
jobs and above all peace
as soon as the timbuktu was liberated
unesco and the malian government
launched a restoration
operation
with logistical support from the blue
helmets of our united nations
peacekeeping missions
like destruction
restoration is not only about buildings
it is about history about identity and
about culture and the promise
of the future for our succeeding
generations
i'm proud to say
that 14 muslims
have now been completely
restored
the towns people talk about the rebirth
of timbuktu
unesco stands ready to travel to palmyra
which was liberated just weeks ago
to help evaluate the damage
and protect the city's priceless
cultural heritage
i hope that one day
palmyra
aleppo
nineveh
and the other devastated cities of syria
and iraq will again serve as symbols of
unity and diversity
the united nations security council
has recognized the important links
between
cultural heritage peace and security
in a landmark resolution and passed last
year
the security council condemned
the destruction of cultural heritage in
iraq and in syria
and adopted legally binding measures to
combat the illicit trafficking
of antiquities
and cultural artifacts from these
countries
this was a rare show of unity
from the security council
which has been in a deadly
deadlock over syrian issues
now we must build on these major steps
to advance the cause of peace
distinguish the presidents
students ladies and gentlemen
another kind of culture erupts
periodically in some societies around
the cultural touchstones
identities and beliefs
attempts to persuade
can sometimes cross a line into attempts
to shut down differing opinions
university campuses
are open at the center of very heated
debate
here too
diverse cultures and opinions
are signs of flourishing community
universities universities
these to be places where we can listen
to each other
and each other's ideas
in peace
there is nothing more important than
preserving respect for dialogue debate
and yes disagreement
when disrespect is lost
deeper damage can be done
this is the place where professors teach
young generation
young generation wilson someday will
become professors
and leaders of the society
this is the way
people learn
and practice
i've been speaking to world leaders
whenever and wherever there are problems
and there are many countries where fires
are burning where people are fighting
against their leaders
i've been speaking to these leaders
please listen very carefully attentively
what
your people are saying
what their aspirations and challenges
are
but sometimes
they do not listen to the voices that's
the beginning of
the problems of the country beginning of
the world problem of the world
now
in such
esteemed educational institutions like
yale universities and
where you represent around the world
these universities should be the places
to teach your students
how
they can listen each other
while exchanging their views they need
to listen to each other's views
that's the basic to mutually understand
each other
and then when they become leaders of the
society whether educational political
social economic i think they
they have capacity they have willingness
to listen to each other
i know university presidents are keenly
aware
of your responsibility to foster
such public dialogue
i congratulate you on your success in
staying at the forefront of intellectual
challenge and change
in the internet age
universities need a passionate debate on
campus
and to remain relevant
i hope the young men and women here
will bring that passion with you
into the world beyond your studies
ladies and gentlemen
the world is at a critical juncture
we need the energy and idealism of young
people
to tackle
major threats to human well-being
this world's global population
the half of them
is under the age of 25.
that means
this year this world is very young
but
have we done enough attention enough
education
enough
for their job opportunities no i don't
think so that's the beginning beginning
of all these problems which we have
therefore these universities must be the
place
where you really educate the good
quality
and it's now politically those economic
leaders community leaders that they
should employ and empower these young
people
that's what i'm really going to
discuss with you
and another important
issue is
how
we can address climate change
is not visible
but is impacting surely
all the spectrums of our life
climate change is an intergenerational
injustice
thank you very much for that divestment
universities when will you i think we
have i know that your university has
already begun divestment
i am very much grateful
for europe
leading by example and i
i highly
approach president salovey for his
vision
now i can tell you that low carbon
economy
is inevitable
it's already happening
and it must be it must be it's
inevitable
in even in some of the wealthiest
countries
nearly half of young adults are
unemployed
conflict
is creating the highest number of
displaced
people since the second world war
half of them are children
some 600 million young people
live in countries
that are fragile or war-torn
the united nations
is responding to these problems
but we need the engagement of young men
and women to multiply our efforts
all world leaders agreed last september
on the ambitious due 20 30 sustainable
development agenda
which aim to end first of all object
poverty by 2030
preventable prevent diseases prevent
those people
who would otherwise die from preventable
diseases
and empower
women by 2030
our target of the united nations
is to make this world 50 to 50
planet earth where men and women will
have a equal standing in every aspect of
our life
this agenda sustainable development
goals known as sdgs instead of mdgs have
17 goals
which include
clear targets for education
gender equality and decent work for all
we are now in the first year of
implementation
i hope young men and women
will hold governments accountable
for their promises
and help to achieve them
and universities
and professors should also be part of
this
now first ever
world humanitarian summit meeting will
be held and in istanbul next month
this will consider root causes of
conflict and displacement
how we can better protect civilians and
how we can meet the needs of
unprecedented
numbers of people
who are moving from here there from
conflict
john to
the better places
the united nations will hold the summit
on in september to discuss this matter i
know that many european leaders are
struggling to handle this matter
but it's not
the european
matters only
there's a human tendency that when there
is a conflict then people have to flee
to protect their own lives
it's a human tendency that people are
moving from one place to another for
better opportunities it happened since
millennials
many thousand years ago people were
constantly having
moving
toward other better places
again this is a very important issue at
this time
the climate change sustainable
development goals
how we can address this humanitarian
crisis all around the world
can you believe that there are
more than 60 million people around the
world who need immediate assistance
life-saving humanitarian assistance
around the world this is the most number
since the end of
second
world war
last december
again
the united nations is making a lot of
landmark decisions
when i was talking about this importance
of youth
for the first time in the history of the
united nations i appointed a special
envoy on youth
it's a young man
but he's now liaising and networking all
around the world with a
youth group
and even security council has adopted a
landmark resolution on youth issues
the important significance of the
security council resolution is that
normally
according to chat of the united nations
security council has a primary
responsibility to deal with
international peace and security
then
many people believe that women issue is
not
nothing to do with the peace and
security team
youth issue has nothing to do with peace
and security but security council
has recognized already 11 years ago
by adopting landmark resolution which is
open quoted
1325 this is women peace and security
today united nations recognized
that already
lack of gender empowerment
has implications to peace and security
of the world now
december last year
they recognized that
youth issue
can have a direct implication to
international peace and security now
united nations are addressing
comprehensively all old issues
far too long
young people
haven't considered good enough to fight
wars only but not to make peace
this is our commitment united nations
commitment to address these issues
finally i hope
young people like yourselves
i think you should lead this campaign
to make this world
sustainable more sustainable
environmentally by addressing climate
action
yale sent
i know that 100 student experts to paris
last year when there was a summit
meeting to support
hard-won climate change agreement
i commend yale
for being the first university to join
the carbon pricing leadership coalition
i have been urging
pension funds insurance companies
and major companies
business companies to start
decarbonizing
their portfolios
and shifting towards greener investment
and student movement and action like
devestment
from fossil to
clean energy
that's what we expect
the universities and educational
institutions and particularly our young
leaders should lead this
campaign
yale has shown great leadership
in this area and i commend your
initiatives
shareholders are calling on cam
companies
they invest
in to disclose climate risk
a growing number of corporations are
speaking up in favor of carbon pricing
i encourage yale to be an even bigger
part of the transition
to a safer
healthier
low-carbon future
the path to prosperity
is clear
and we should all do what we can
to put the world on more sustainable
footing i was very much grateful while
walking to this
auditorium prince salovey explained
how
yale universities
trying to make
carbon
low carbon
of management of this and i thank you
very much you you're leading by example
i'm encouraged
by the strong political momentum from
more than 130 countries
that have confirmed their intention to
sign
this paris agreement on 22nd
of this month
this thing is the present
dear
young students ladies and gentlemen
there is a syrian saying i quote
without the old
there is nothing new
without the historical context
we cannot make sense of our world or
build the common future
universities have a critical role
in preserving
and sharing knowledge
and instilling respect for cultural
heritage
and diversity
you are training the next generation
of cultural curators
and leaders
academics of all disciplines know that
without open debate
research stagnates and progress slows to
a stand still
above all
you understand the critical link between
culture and human development
i urge you
to lead a global movement
to promote our diverse cultural heritage
for future generations
engage your colleagues
your friends
your students
and your teachers
preserving the world's priceless
cultural heritage is a task for all of
us
ladies and gentlemen let us work
together
to make this world better for
all the people around the world i thank
you for your attention thank you for
your engagement and leadership thank you
very much
thank you very much uh thank you
secretary general
secretary general has uh agreed to take
some questions and i was handed on my
way in a stack of three by five cards
which i
presume
you all uh filled out earlier
uh this afternoon
um
and i'll just take them in the order in
which uh i receive them
uh so this is a
question about palmyra uh talking about
uh how much of it was destroyed during
the occupation
uh of the islamic state
and uh there's two questions here one
one which you addressed in your talk the
first question is what is the role of
the international community in helping
to rebuild
sites like palmyra which you did speak a
bit about
but the other question uh maybe you
could
elaborate upon which is what really can
universities
do to help with a situation like that
i think most of you must have read the
newspapers i think it was about two
weeks ago
one very brave reporter visited palmyra
at the destruction site
i was appalled
to see all this complete destruction of
thousand-year-old
our cultural heritages
unesco
and united nations
when a situation improves through
political negotiation when the security
allows us
that we will immediately begin
to
restore as much as we can
this
priceless
valuable artifact that's one commitment
which was already announced by director
general of unesco a few weeks ago we
will do that
then
for that possible
the syrian people
should have peace
in their homes home country
that's why from tomorrow
the negotiation is going to
resume
in geneva
with my
special envoy for syria
chairing
we've been trying to
make a political space
as much as possible
and
through two meetings
we've been trying to
find out some commonalities
commonalities common elements between
two
worrying parties
we have found at least 12 common
elements
one of 12 common elements
includes the reconstruction
of syria
when there is all the agreements are
done
we can see
relative peace
and security so that all these experts
can
can enter and engage in reconstruction
social economic recurrence
reconstruction and restoration of
cultural heritages
universities
you have a
very important role you have produced
many
important political leaders business
community leaders i think this is the
place where president and prime
ministers and business ceos and
educators they are all educated here so
you are the teachers of all the leaders
around the world i think you have a lot
of
reach and influence and use your
influence as teachers
of those political leaders and
business field ceos there is nothing
which one country can do
i think all the hands should be on the
deck
but academic institutions
that's the place where we can expect the
most influence
and teaching for those people that's
what and that's why i'm here i'm here to
talk with you
thank you thank you
this is a question about that moves from
the middle east and says what other
areas of the world
where we
where we should be concerned about what
are the other areas of the world
where we should be con
concerned about preserving cultural
heritage in the future and what could
the international community do now
in advance of conflict
to build local capacity for such
preservation
i just
introduced my experience in timbuktu and
northern mali a few years ago when
this area was occupied by all these
extremists and destroyed
fortunately we were able with the united
nations peacekeeping missions
in
we were able to liberate the timbuktu
and we
as i said unesco has restored all 16
muslims
that's one
good things
it's not only in mali
we have
at least
10
big fire spawning places
including syria
mali
somalia libya south sudan central
african republic
unfortunately these are all happening in
africa and yemen
yemen even so in yemen
since yesterday the cessation of
hostilities have begun
but it's a very fragile situations are
continuing
under these circumstances
when it comes to human being
is women and girls
a vulnerable group of people
who have been targeted who have been
abused their human rights is now when it
comes to something
then these
historical artifacts
they have become
easy targets
to erase
identity of a certain religion
this is a totally unacceptable situation
therefore
first of all priority is that we should
have a peace restored
and we have to work together how we can
make sure that
each and every
respect the others tradition the others
in history the others
culture but my religion my culture is
important
the same should be applied to other
people who believes
other religions that their religions
their culture tradition should also be
respected
that's why united nations has launched
this alliance of civilization
this is a big initiative but still
it has not been fully
fully able to
address this issue it's very sad we are
living in a very
difficult
era
at the same time as i said
it's not only perils or challenges
we have world leaders have given some
strong sense of hope
through
agenda for sustainable development
targeting 2030 and climate change
agreement these two are i think a most
most encouraging
achievement that the united nations and
international community have achieved
and presented
in recent years in recent years
therefore while we address these
crisis issues
we have to pay more attention and
priority on development and climate
change issues by doing that we can
significantly reduce
the
sources of conflict that's my belief yes
maybe we should turn to sustainability
and climate change
pick up on a couple of themes in your
from your talk
this is a question
essentially saying
what are the next steps following cop21
in paris and do we need a different
approach in the developed and in the
developing world
cup 21
was
it's not the end
or it's not the beginning
we may say it was a good beginning but
turning point
very significant turning point
as you may
know
you've been following
that the negotiation on climate change
has been very slow
it took decades
that's why i've been
very emphatically emotionally stating
that
negotiation has been moving at the
snails of space snails pace that has
been
many times
quoted by media
it has been moving even slower than
snails
last year and since 2014
i have been pushing and accelerating
this pace
and during my time as a secretary
general journalist for 10 years
i have convinced at least three times
special summon meeting on climate change
and my
convening power
and 2014
the last meeting before we went to paris
that was the most turning point
most of the world leaders came and there
were huge
show of solidarity by the people
in new york in manhattan there were 400
000 people marched
calling for action
and it was not only in manhattan all
throughout the world
that was a turning point
i am very happy
that
in cop 21
this paris agreement was agreed adopted
by unanimity
it's dramatic and amazing that
out of 196 countries
even one country objects
there could not have been any
agreement but all 196 countries agreed
because
they know that without taking action now
it will be too late
we'll be
abandoning
the moral and political duties
of
this world
i'm very happy but this is not the end
we have to build upon this one all this
agreement should be implemented without
fail
that's why one good thing is that
we have in deplo
introduced
a monitoring
and verifying
mechanisms every five years
there will be a monitoring and
verification process it will start from
2018. so first
review session
will be held three years after from then
on every five years
then we expect
these parties member states would
raise their level of ambition this
ambition level at this time is low
while we agreed
to contain
the global temperature rise below 2
degrees centigrade
but if we continue like this way then in
may and we may end up at least three
degrees
then it will be a charging
tragic situation so we have to do even
lower than two degrees 1.5 degrees i
think we can do it with the
transformative for technology
development
and with the low carbon economy with the
sustainable energy
deployed
i think we can do it and therefore i've
been asking
major business
community leaders
to the best
enforcer in the fossil fuel industries
to sustainable energy solar energy wind
power
and all these what
water hydro hydro powers these are the
answers and it is
inevitable
and it is already taking place and i'm
sure that we will be able to make it
yeah
if i could combine two questions that
came in uh really about yale's policies
toward
becoming more sustainable
greener campus
you mentioned that yale was the first
university to join the carbon pricing
leadership coalition which
the world bank and the imf launched in
paris
and we want to be a laboratory
for carbon pricing
whether it works to change
change behavior and what are the
political
constraints and issues that need to be
resolved in order to implement it beyond
a university we've started here and
so the first question is do you think
experiments of this kind uh are useful
you you did comment on it a little bit
the other one relates to the issue that
uh some of our students care quite
passionately about and
we're here
making that view
apparent that concerns divestment
from
investments
in companies engaged in
extraction or sale of fossil fuels
our
chief investment officer has
carved out a strategy that i believe he
may be the only one doing what he did is
he wrote to all of yael's fund managers
a letter and our our endowment is law is
essentially managed externally by by
fund managers
and he encouraged them to consider the
risks of climate change
in their investment decisions
and he's about to announce the results
of this letter
uh
i believe there's actually going to be
an article in the new york times
tomorrow about this maybe already online
and what he says is that the results
have been significant in both in terms
of selling
past investments
and uh refraining from some new ones so
this is kind of an economic based
approach rather than wholesale
divestment it sort of
approaches it over time as an investment
decision
over time so the question is whether you
think this is a useful way to move the
global economy toward uh greater use of
clean energy technology
my answer is of course definitely is a
very commentable
very good
initiative
and normally
one may think that climate change
sustainable development and that's what
government leaders do or that's what
business communities
will have to do
but
universities
and educational institutions are no
exception
in their regard
i was so happy to
i'm so happy to hear that
yale universities is really leading by
example when you teach
you have to lead
you have to practice
what my role sometimes as a secretary
general
is a lot of preaching
when you just preach and if you don't do
it
it's not fair
you have to do as you preach
you have to do as you teach
this is what you are showing
and
i believe that what your chief financial
officer has been doing with all this
business communities dealing with your
universities i think that's a fantastic
idea
and
this
this may sound a small initiative i hope
that the the presence of
for participating here
i should
emulate
and when you return
your university should also do
the exactly what
yale university is doing
at the same time i appreciate some of
the students who
stood up with the panels
when you implement this
crime climate change and sustainable
development goals
and sometimes you need activism
we normally think that activism is for
what the ngos or civil societies
and business ceos government officials
are always defensive
they always try to say something then
defensive
it's only
the civil society and ngos will really
provoke and challenge and motivate
government officials and business
communities i really appreciate your
activism
i'm asking young students
you may even challenge your professors
you may challenge your
congressmen senators and presidents
you have that prerogative
because
you have fresh ideas and creative ideas
then
most of all this is the world where you
will have to live
i'm
you know my term ends december this year
so i'll become a just a normal citizen
and professors one day president one day
you may retire then that's
your your place it will be your place
and therefore
you have a legitimate right to challenge
your community and leaders then look
professor senators
mr president this is my world this is
the place where i
i will have to leave my children will
have to live please make this world
sustainable
economically socially
as a final question
uh one that's a little bit more uh
self-reflective
uh and that is about you
uh
january as you said will mark 10 years
as u.n secretary general
and the completion of your second term
and this question asks what leadership
lessons
uh have you learned in this ten years
and in particular
what are the challenges for the u.n of
the future and are there any leadership
lessons that our students can take away
from your experience
at the u.n
there's a little broad broadcast
which is a very difficult
i think
the leadership when you talk about
leadership
i don't think there is any
clear cut the definition of leadership
that should be different from
where
what kind of profession
where you are placed in
but my leadership
as a secretary general or
senior
public
public service servant
should always be listening
listening
to the voices of the people
then what can i do for them what they
are really thinking
what their aspirations are what are
their concerns and challenges are
this is what i have been doing then
often i've been saying that
i'm a defender of defenseless people
i'm a voice of voiceless people there
are many people you will be surprised to
know that
there are many voiceless people
many vulnerable group of people who are
completely defenseless
where and when their human rights and
human dignity are just
ruthlessly
abused
then i've been speaking out for them
i've been speaking up for them
this is one aspect of leadership
but when you
lead your long life
seventy years or eight years
i often say that
the highest virtue
of a human being
is to look
act like water
this is what i talked to president obama
and one day
i wrote
some calligraphy
and gave this to president obama
mr president i think your leadership
looks like water
what
i believe in
and i hope
if anybody agrees with my points please
try to practice but it's not easy
it's not easy
water seems to be just powerless
weakest
no power nothing
but
water
is very powerful
when it has to when it
definitely has to be
there are many important elements in our
world
there are some fiery people very dynamic
leadership who speak so fiery and very
eloquently
but do they really practice
do they really know how to
make a compromise and some flexible
flexibility
this is what i have seen among so many
leaders
they are seemingly very dynamic but do
not know how to make some
harmonious
decision harmonious conclusion of a
debate
if you just insist your
views
suppose you may be right
but that's not the end
you may you cannot be hundred percent
right older times there is always
some good points to listen to others
views and make the others views
as yours
and combine it make it harmonious
when i
believe in this
theory of water
the highest virtue is to act like water
you don't need to always to confront
when there is something
hazard
then you may just
avoid all this
unnecessary you don't need to confront
all the times
but when it is absolutely necessary
you can push
you can really push hard this is what we
see from
water
water doesn't have color
water doesn't have any order
water doesn't seemingly doesn't have any
power but in the end
it can't win over anything can fire wind
over water
everybody believes the fire is
has a deadly force
but it's water to
extinguish
and
still even still
cannot win over
water
wood
earth or whatever
in our life
in the regard if you believe in that if
you
act like water
i'm sure that you will be respected by
all the people around you that's my
belief but it's up to you
thank you
i want to thank all of you for coming uh
today and especially to uh those of you
who submitted questions
and uh want to thank you for an
excellent address and for taking those
questions
thank you very much
so
you